it is history in the making the second
impeachment trial of former president
trump begins in the senate he is charged
with inciting the capital assault that
resulted in the deaths of five people
including
a capitol police officer natalie brandt
has details in washington
in the same chamber that was stormed by
a mob of rioters on january 6
senators who were then eyewitnesses are
now jurors
in the historic second impeachment trial
of former president trump
accused of inciting the insurrection the
resolution is agreed to
first the senate approved a resolution
setting the rules then debate began over
whether the proceedings are
constitutional
they hated the results of the 2016
election
and want to use this impeachment process
to further their political agenda
mr trump's attorneys argue the senate
lacks the authority to try a president
who's no longer in office
while impeachment managers led by
constitutional scholar jamie raskin say
that argument has been rejected by legal
experts across the political spectrum
this cannot be the future of america we
cannot have
presidents inciting and mobilizing mob
violence against
our government a simple majority of
senators ultimately voted that the
proceedings are
constitutional setting the stage for the
rest of the trial
starting wednesday which is exactly five
weeks since the deadly capital riot
both sides will each have 16 hours over
two days to present their cases
senior aides to the house impeachment
manager said tuesday they plan to
present evidence nobody has seen before
president trump is singularly and
directly responsible
for inciting the assault on the capitol
we have
counter arguments to everything that
they raised
it's still unclear whether witnesses may
be called but the former president
is not expected to appear his attorneys
rejected that request calling it a
public relations stunt
as the trial continues inside the
capitol outside the national guard and
capitol police remain on high security
alert
natalie brand cbs news capitol hill